guys i just don't get it i do not
understand for the life of me i kind of
can get it if i really try to think
about it but then there's a big part of
me that just doesn't get it don't over
rationalize it it doesn't make much
sense
so i've had um
many people friends colleagues project
on to me that i i shouldn't do these
kinds of videos you know like we've done
stuff with warner brothers and i've been
like i don't know i feel like when i'm
honest if i don't like something like if
i like [ __ ] on mortal kombat or
conjuring three they still work with us
i'm like i feel like i i'd rather be
honest and lose any working relationship
because we don't have like a strong
relationship with them because every
once in a while they hook us up with
some goodies you know yeah like
malignant stuff
or whatever to maintain these
relationships yeah but we don't like
have like people we just call upon for
help or something we don't know either
of the warner brothers so either way
here's what's going on with zack
snyder's justice league in case you guys
didn't know is available on blu-ray
right now uh you can go buy it off
amazon or at your local store although
i've seen some people say that they've
gone to actual stores and they've been
sold out which is a good sign now there
might be a reason you don't know that
it's out it's because warner brothers is
really trying to bury it and this to me
is one of the clearest indicators ever
that they really are doing whatever they
can to make people forget about this and
just how much shade they really have
towards zack snyder all right there's no
other way to put it if you guys remember
after zack snyder's justice league came
out they eventually released the trailer
for the justice league on their warner
brothers page the 4k blu-ray release it
was met with abysmal like to dislike
ratio to say the least it was not a good
maneuver on their end poor timing
terrible timing and never would have
been good timing to begin with
so that happened now i've learned this
from a friend alex lobo you might have
heard him mention on 3c films uh him and
i are buzz on social media and he
messaged me just asking about did you
hear that they said zack snyder's
justice league to
unlisted the trailer release for this i
was like what
so i i checked it out and i
when i say i couldn't believe it i
couldn't believe it apparently this
trailer has been out for two weeks
already by the point of us filming this
this trailer's been out for two weeks
it's got 77 000 views just through the
power of fandom sharing this trailer and
warner brothers never made it public
there's three things you usually have i
mean there's other options with the main
three when you upload a video to youtube
are public like while you're watching
this video now how you got notification
bells yada yada private meaning only you
can watch the video yourself and
unlisted meaning if you share this link
other people can watch it does not mean
it's going to show up an algorithm
people's feeds notification bells only
way you can see it is through
individuals sharing it and uh frankly
it's a shitty maneuver to do i think
it's a terrible maneuver of what they
did to this film and why i say i don't
get it i'm like okay i've reached the
point where i understand you don't have
a good relationship with snyder you
don't have a good relationship with
snyder cut fans especially the fans who
don't really like anything else outside
of the dc eu excluding snyder films that
i get like i'm not one of those people
and john isn't either the suicide squad
is one of my favorite movies i've seen
this year which i know zack snyder you
know did executive produce along with
deborah but it's still not a like a
snyder film right and i'm excited for
the batman and all these other dc movies
that are coming out too like i it would
be a
total lie and just nothing but pandering
for me to say that i'm not excited for
those movies at the same time though i'm
like okay i get i can kind of see why
you're distancing like yeah i get it but
what do you have to lose by putting this
like you you paid the money to produce
the blu-rays you paid the money to
manufacture this you paid the money to
cut the trailer you you invest in money
and now you're just like i'm willing to
lose more money now for some reason
you're pushing the justice league one
which you wouldn't know is just gonna be
met with hatred but you don't
just let this be public because what
you're afraid of comments like
so weird because hey yeah what comments
would you be afraid of because the court
of public opinion is clearly on the side
of this cut of the movie and yeah it's a
piece of promotional material so why
make it and then not promote that piece
of material the easiest way possible by
setting it live on youtube and part of
me goes well maybe it was an oversight
by some intern but i'm like no it's that
it's been two weeks it can't be because
a yes somebody would have gone to wb and
been like hey did you notice this isn't
getting as many views as it ought to and
b yeah after just the saga of the snyder
cut versus wb this does seem just like
another in a long line of very strange
and kind of spiteful choices yeah it's
like we made a trailer it's kind of
available
except you have to really track it down
or find you know an article that
re-linked it or something it's not just
readily available you know and that's my
point is like the only way people know
about this is through the fan base i
know it from a fellow fan you guys
should follow on youtube
or on twitter he's got a great twitter
constantly working on the flash leaks
it's like don't you know this would only
upset the snyder fans more it's like
okay let's say you make this trailer
public you already decided to
manufacture the blu-rays release them
you make the trailer public you would at
least have a positive response in the
fact that they're releasing it you would
have a positive response of the like to
dislike ratio way better than the other
one it would be a much better received
trailer than your 4k blu-ray release of
the justice league and sure would it be
met with a bunch of comments that are
saying hashtag restore the snyder burst
what are you doing wb all you got people
yelling about that right yeah i get it
they would say that but they were going
to find out about this unlisted thing
and now all you've done is pissed those
people off even more yeah
so all you've done is really literally
throw fuel to the flames by not making
it public that's all you've done and now
we're here doing a video to tell you
guys you can go watch the unlisted
trailer in the pinned comments go watch
it give it some luck give it some
support okay 200k views i really
couldn't believe it when alex told me
about this i was so
like baffled by whoa
i can't believe they pulled this
this is a gnarly thing to learn about to
be honest really is strange anyway guys
what are your thoughts on the matter
here leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and i hope next time we talk
about snyder versus not more bs because
it's more bv
yeah something else right the
there's gotta be something else but uh
yeah leave your thoughts down below and
hey let's do a page
gene
the jeter i want a jeter cut of zack
snyder's justice league and don't look
at me like you are not capable of doing
that seeing the vision of zack snyder
then combined with your vision well the
possibilities are endless gene plus
imagine you know so many like
picturesque looking people all the
models you work with you could easily
fill out and shoot your own original
content for this make your own
themaskira get your own like new york
batmobile thing going on like a bat tank
or something like that cut it up all
avant-garde put in sepia tone instead of
black and white or something like that
gene throw us a curve ball man that's
all i want now is cuts of other people's
movies by different artists and you are
where i want to start sir because no
matter what i know that will be one
interesting ass motion picture
all four hours worth so uh love you gene
stay creative stay yourself and uh we'll
catch you next time catch you next time
buddy
[Music]
you